aujourd'hui près de 60% de la population
mondiale vit sous des dictatures ou des
régions météoritaires ça doit nous
interpeller pour réfléchir à l'avenir de
notre politique commerciale voulons-nous
seulement conclure des accords de
commerce avec des pays qui ne sont dit
des démocraties que faisons-nous avec
des régimes motoritaires prenons
l'exemple de la Chine nous le voyons
bien à la Chine a une vision du monde
totalement différente de la nôtre et
nous sommes dépendants pour autant de la
Chine comment voulons-nous rééquilibrer
cette dépendance comment voulons-nous
aussi au travers de cette politique
commerciale faire bouger les choses pour
la réalité pour faire en sorte par
exemple que le travail des enfants ne
soit plus mise en place c'est pourquoi
nous mettons en place notamment ce que
nous appelons n'importe ban c'est à dire
bannir les produits
issus du travail forcé à nos frontières
notre politique commerciale est donc un
outil essentiel pour défendre la
démocratie pour se battre pour nos
valeurs nous le faisons aussi à travers
la réforme dit des chapitres
développement durables ces chapitres
développements durables ils traitent au
développement durable mais aussi la
question des droits humains les droits
du travail cette réforme des chapitres
développement durable va nous permettre
progressivement en fait de fermer
l'accès à notre marché intérieur si nos
partenaires ne respectent pas leur
engagements que nous avons permis
d'avoir dans des futurs accords de
commerce on le voit bien en matière de
politique donc extérieur la politique
commerciale joue un levier fondamental
mais pour autant somme nous prêts à
conclure n'importe quel accord de
commerce non prenons l'exemple du
Mercosur nous nous réjouissons que Le
président Lula gagne les élections au
Brésil c'est fondamental pour la
démocratie mais cet accord il pose
encore des questions sur le fond sur la
question du changement climatique mais
aussi sur la concurrence déloyale pour
nos agriculteurs donc nous le voyons
bien la politique commerciale est un
enjeu
extrêmement complexe pour lequel il nous
faut continuer de définir une voix qui
ne soit pas celle de l'ouverture
délétère ni celle de la fermeture
délétère mais véritablement une
politique commerciale qui nous permette
de défendre nos intérêts nos ambitions
et nos valeurs nos valeurs démocrates